welcome back almost ran a time of that
last video so let's just start from the
beginning for problem number 14 so I
drew the figure and they told us you
know that this line is perpendicular to
that line and they drew it here and that
this is perpendicular to that they drew
it there they told us this was 125
degrees this is X and then the one piece
of information they tell us is that Ln
this line is equal to L M and I marked
it here and what we said at the end of
the last video is well if these two
sides are equal we also know from
geometry class the base angles are also
going to be equal and then let's see
what we can do with that whether we can
figure out X well the first step we can
do is we can say well if this is 125
degrees what is this angle right here
well they're going to have to add up to
180 because they're supplementary so
this is going to be what's 180 minus 1
25 or it's 80 minus 25 it's 55 degrees
this is 55 degrees right and then if
that is if generation I'm doing my math
right right that's 55 so that's 55 then
this is also going to be 55 and then if
if these are both 55 what is this angle
up here well they're all in the triangle
so they have to add up to 180 so 55 + 55
is 110 so this one has to be 70 degrees
right or 180 minus 1 10 right they have
to add up to 180 degrees so this is 70
degrees right here and now can we figure
out what this angle is here this is what
I call the angle game you just have to
keep figuring out angles well if this is
70 degrees what this angle plus this
angle they're going to be complementary
right they're going to come out to 90
because this is 90 so all we have left
is 90 degrees here so if these two have
to add up to 90 degrees and this is 20
degrees 20 degrees that says 2800 really
small you probably can't read it all
right because this we know that this
this whole thing is a right angle
because this is a right angle so this is
90 we know that this whole thing is 90
so this is 20 and now finally I think
we're ready for X because X plus 90 plus
20 has to be equal 180 because it's
in the same triangle so x plus 90 plus
20 is equal to 180 x plus 1 1002 180 x
is equal to 70 degrees and we are done
next problem problem number 15 a
measuring cup contains one-fifth a cup
of orange juice one-fifth a cup of
orange juice orange juice it is then
filled to the one cup mark that is a
mixture containing equal amounts of
orange grapefruit and pineapple juices
what fraction of the final mixture is
orange juice oh this is interesting so
you have one fifth already orange juice
and then the next four fifths the next
four fifths is going to be equal parts
all right because are going to filter
the one cup fine it's going to be equal
parts orange grapefruit great i'll just
write grape and pineapple pineapple i
have to do three right so the next four
fist is going to be split amongst these
three so it's equally right so how much
more orange juice are we putting it well
we took four fifths and one-third of
this for fist is going to be orange
juice so the amount of orange juice
we're putting in now is one-third times
the four fifths right so we're putting
in 415 orange juice and we already had
one fifth orange juice so one fifth plus
4 15 that equals 3 15 plus 4 15's which
equals 7 15 that is how much that is the
final mixture of orange juice and does
that make sense intuitively right that
makes sense because this is like twenty
percent orange juice and then we're
adding maybe a little bit a little bit
less than a fourth so we'll have a
little
bit less than a half in the glass all
right next problem this is the phone
number my cousin's answer seems a little
suspicious she had marked up this book
all right problem number 16 if a plus to
be a plus to be is equal to one hundred
twenty five percent of four be so that
equals 125 percent another if you want
to write a hundred twenty-five percent
as a decimal which I like to do it's
1.25 one hundred twenty-five percent of
4b what is the value of a over B so we
want to figure out a over B let's just
solve this thing so a plus 2 b is equal
to what's 1.25 times for if you have a
dollar 25 and you do have that four
times that's five right four times one
and then four times a quarter that's
another dollar that's five B and then
subtract to be from both sides you get a
is equal to 3 be divide both sides by B
and you get a over B is equal to three
and you are done the problem problem
number 17
okay they have a number line see this
number line I'm just how much have to
draw this number line to minimize my
drawing you say zero is here what is
here and then they drew like how many
hash marks rather see one two three four
five six seven eight hash marks okay oh
it says they're on the number line above
there are nine equal intervals between 0
and 1 what is the what is the value of x
so there's you know right now 123456789
right I have nine equal intervals and
then X is X is right I'm just make sure
I draw it correctly we have two marks
and then we have X and actually we have
the square root of x so there are nine
equal intervals right so we could just
view well this is one ninth this is two
nights this is three nights right four
nights this is 89 this is 99 right is 89
this is 79 this is six nights right this
is 59 all right because nine equal
intervals so we know that the square
root of x is equal to six over nine
square both sides well what six over
nine that's the same thing as 2 over 3
right so you square both sides so you
get x is equal to 49 2 squared three
squared we are done next problem midge
clear image invert colors all right
problem 18
in the XY coordinate plane the distance
between point B so B is the point 10
comma 18 the distance between the point
B and the point ay ay is comma is point
X comma 3 so the distance is 17 between
these points what is one possible value
of x so a this is the distance formula
and the distance formula is really just
the Pythagorean theorem so we what we do
is we say well the distance squared is
you know the distance squared is equal
to the change in x squared plus the
change in Y squared and this is really
just the Pythagorean theorem and if you
haven't learned that yet you can
actually i don't think i've got a
distance formula video that's on my
to-do list but i'll do that but it's
just the Pythagorean theorem so the
distance squared so 17 squared is equal
to what's the change in X so let's just
call that 10 minus X 10 minus x squared
plus plus and then we know that a change
in Y so 18-3 so it's 15 squared 15
squared and what's the sign of 15
squared is 225 this is going to be equal
to x squared minus 20x x squared minus
20x and then because it could be plus
100 and then we have what 17 squared 17
x 17 7 times 7 is 49 1 times 7 is 7 plus
4 is 11 0 for 17 it is 289 289 and so
then we have let's see and then we can
subtract 289 from both sides you get 0
is equal to x squared minus 20x plus add
these two together 325 minus 2 89
I only have 10 seconds left so I'll do
it in the next video